there is no meaning there is only lore I
need to get my notes out I need to get
you staggered back into the house with a
certain look about you oh boy did I ever
all right so I just got back from glass
okay
2019 glass the sequel to split which was
the stealth sequel side cool to
unbreakable I think I like I'm breakable
a little less after seeing this welded
was it okay no no it was not okay
it was not okay
so that actually just well we're talking
about unbreakable one of the first
things so there's a scene in the kind of
the middle ish of the movie where all of
a sudden I'm sitting there thinking like
wow Bruce Willis remembered how to act
again and it took me a couple more
seconds to realize wait no this is
literally just a scene from unbreakable
they just reused they just read yeah
they just reused a substantial amount of
footage from unbreakable curious okay
yeah so there's there's at least two
full sequences that are just included
straight from straight from it and then
a bunch of other like small smaller
clips ditto with splice the less of
splice is used split split splice isn't
it spicy very different movie very very
different movie it is a very cheap movie
Oh like okay so split so I just saw
split for the first time last night
hated it awful movie now I do suspect
that a little bit or at least a
substantial bit of my like dislike of
split stems a lot from kind of the
foreknowledge that it's like okay well
glass comes out tomorrow
your represents controversial spoiler
opinions
it is indeed possible for I would say
that my viewing of split was indeed
ruined by the spoiler of knowing that it
is the prequel to glass rather than the
movie ruining itself by revealing that
it is in fact the pretty culture glass
so instead of getting angry after the
movie ended I got angry as the movie was
going is really how that is really all
that that changed it just advanced the
anger by you know ninety minutes but so
this is a very cheap movie if you're
gonna look at the budget and so this lit
was actually made for like nine million
dollars which in terms of a which which
in terms of a Hollywood movie is
basically free that is very very
low-budget there are you know a lot of
indie films made with made with higher
budgets so it was made for nine million
dollars this one was probably made for
substantially more and one hundred and
ten percent of that increase was Bruce
Willis and Samuel Jackson's salary of
course like that is of course so if if
this one was made for even a hair over
thirty million I would be shocked and I
would easily say that 25 of those were
in just those two salaries so almost the
entire budget of the movie was simply
paint just paying those two actors and
there was no budget left over for pretty
much anything else yeah so so split one
of the things that I became aware of
about halfway through it's like oh this
is a bottle movie and so when I looked
up the budget and it was only nine
million I wasn't surprised because it's
like 80% takes place in one location I
love I love bottle episodes the notion
of bottle episodes so now we had a
bottle there's a bottle movie you know
now bottle movies are not intrinsically
bad 10 Cloverfield Lane as a bottle and
it's it was fantastic it makes great use
of great use of that format so like the
format is not intrinsically flawed but
you know
you you start to sense when a movie has
not really been written with or around
the constraints but has been is is just
trying to be squeezed into and like
tries to tries to trick you in in subtle
ways and this is the most M night movie
ever
oh everything so okay everything that
was insufferable about the writing of
lady in the water how like you had all
of this meta commentary on like the
nature of screenwriting and storytelling
in just like the most head up ass way
possible yeah that's all back except now
it's not just there now it's also
peppered liberally with comic-book
vocabulary so it's already head up ass
and it's also just like unbearably
cringe-worthy
all right audio died in 2000 in in 2000
comic book movies were not we're not
marketable so it was you know kind of
this stealth this stealth comic book
movie but really it was a family drama
centered around a very kind of grounded
sense of superheroes that it's like what
if superhero mythology is basically just
a oh and this guy tip what a superhero
mythology is basically just a light
exaggeration of actual things and so
David Dunn's powers in unbreakable are
are very nebulous and very constrained
he is very he is resilient he's
resilient he's strong that's kinda it
and there's this whole you know there's
there's explicitly a scene where his son
like pulls a gun on him and it's all the
tension is about land he actually take a
bullet his son is convinced that dad's
Superman he just wants to prove it to
his dad by pulling it down on him and
they have to talk him down
yeah and it's it's tense because we
don't know David doesn't know no nobody
knows and and it's like not gonna find
out because if you find out the hard way
it's not and one of the things kind of
it then goes through that is that you
know David's weakness quote every air
quotes air quote weakness is that he can
drown and so this is again kind of that
like you know exaggeration element it's
like all Superman has kryptonite and
it's like well David's weakness is that
he's normal yeah in regards to he must
breathe air and is thus capable of
drowning water doesn't like take away
his powers it's just terrifying because
he's the same as anyone same as anyone
else so you go from being and vulnerable
to being vulnerable and by and large the
movie works because it's it's a lot of
metaphor like it's leaning very heavily
into the fact that into this whole idea
of superpowers as themselves metaphors
so David is unbreakable he is he is
physically unyielding but he's also
emotionally unyielding which means that
he's unable to open up to his family
he's unable to be emotionally vulnerable
and that causes him tons of problems in
in his life and so you know the the
unbreakable man needs to learn to be
vulnerable
I guess his other power is that he can
like sense evil and again this is kind
of like I mean it's it's psychic powers
but it's like heightened intuition he
was already working security basically
so and there it was a skill he already
possessed taken to an exaggerated yeah
then it's like he can already read a
crowd and identify who is looking to
cause mischief and it's like okay all
right god
so glass okay now that we've established
the baseline well just and at the end of
unbreakable the twist reveal was that
Samuel Jackson's character had been
deliberately sabotaging trains waiting
for the miracle survivor yes so he had
being his theory he had been
manufacturing mass casualty events okay
so there was a there's like three that
are referenced so like a hotel fire and
an airliner accident and then the train
crash
I'm hazy on the second one I remember
the hotel fire and I remember that was
that was surgery and we reveal that you
know he had been killing mass numbers of
people looking for his chosen one
yeah looking for his opposite and the
thing about that reveal is that it's
like Samuel Jackson isn't a super
villain he's just he's he's just a dude
who has convinced himself that he's Oz
man Diaz because he's read The Watchmen
ten too many times
yeah that he he knows how it actually
works yeah he knows the real way of
things but but he's really just he's
just a very unfortunate man who has
taken his pain in extremely unhealthy
unhealthy directions yeah and so so that
leads to this movie okay where he is in
fact actually like super coordinator
mastermind oh that's unfortunate so one
of the big one of the big twists that I
didn't even really realize was going to
be a twist because I had already pieced
it together watching
split is that Kevin who is James
McAvoy's character okay aka the horde
and they use their character names a lot
that's unfortunate
and in fact because they say the beast
so often I kept having flashbacks to
other comic book adjacent property
infamous where the villain of infamous
to is the beast and the Beast is headed
for fake New Orleans - oh just smash it
just have a crossover with all comic
book characters name of the beast yeah
just have Disney's beast show up - just
a field of beasts so they say that they
said that but so James McAvoy's
character his whole thing is that he has
he has dissociative identity disorder
okay and they say it out loud like it's
not it's they say just associative
identity disorder a lot in both movies
he has dissociative identity disorder
because his mother with OCD like whipped
him with a coat hanger as a kid so he
was in an abusive household so child
abuse gave him dissociative identity
disorder which then gave him superpowers
oh dear because he only has superpowers
when the Beast is in control so the
entire premise of split okay is that
there's this doctor trying to prove that
the some people with dissociative
identity disorder it's not just like
fractured personalities it's not just
protective layers of
compartmentalization it is in fact
distinct people and that the the
different identities can in fact have
like correlating physiologic
Changez so like one of Kevin's
identities has diabetes and others are
like stronger or weaker and the beast is
like super jacked up roid man cannibal
cannibal oh and he can climb walls okay
childhood abuse gave him superpowers
gave him superpowers but now so yeah so
uh his dad was trying to figure out how
to help him and get him away from his
mother okay
don't worry there's this gets even worse
I mean if she was physically abusing him
with a coat hanger regularly you don't
think doesn't seem very difficult but so
there's a scene where she and Kevin
dropped dad off at the train station and
he gets on the same train David was on
that Alijah sabotage and they have they
try to do this really clever cut where
they go from the new footage and like
pan over into the footage from
unbreakable oh and I probably would have
been I don't know more impressed by it
if it wasn't clearly cheap like the
Wendy's rather old footage at this point
try it so in well the the transition is
done it's just it's so clearly like
there's so many things that are done
where it's like oh they've just reused
footage because you know it would save
the money it would cost them less to
license the unbreakable footage from
Buena Vista then it would cost to like
literally shoot another scene yeah yeah
so mr. glass created the Beast by
trapping Kevin with his abusive mother
thus necessitating that Kevin developed
the Beast for protection so but how did
he know this kid had the potential to
become a superhuman was he just doing
this know so many
waiting to see if wonder cuts well no so
it's just a byproduct so this is
supposed to be like oh like entwined
destinies that it's like you know that
that the beasts destiny and David's
destiny are entwined because of these
coincidences it's it's fate
okay but it's also a work of fiction
which it then constantly reminds you of
because everybody is talking about you
know narrative devices all the way
through it and and thus calls attention
to its the fact that it is itself a
contrivance
and it's not very clever we are like 1%
through my notes okay okay let's find
alright so it's a very cheap movie it's
a bottle movie they okay so after after
the the like initial setup which oh it's
giving me okay so so David and his son
have in the span of time between
unbreakable and and glass gone into
business as a father-son like home
security outfit but also a me scratching
it paper but also parallel to that do
like crime fighting on the side Blake
not that his son had any superpowers no
so his son is is like sit back at base
on the radio like listening to the
police scanner and typing things on the
computer he's dispatched he's dispatched
there's zero effort put in the the
acting is atrocious
it's all very very very flat but so that
whole bit like so it's like he he
figures out where James MacAvoy
has a bunch of a bunch of cheerleaders
chained up in a brick factory oh and
there's a very short confrontation and
then the next hour and a half actually
really the next rest of the movie take
place at this hospital that they then
get locked up and they basically get
sent to Arkham where where Elijah has
been kept for the last 19 years I was
about to say where his yeah last time so
of course of course coincidentally
that's where they go and so this doctor
then gets introduced who's trying to
like cure them of the delusion that they
are superheroes or super-powered okay
now this ends up being very bizarre
because her methods and her goals are
for the most part like incomprehensible
okay and it requires that the movie
never behave even remotely logically
like part of this is going to be the
Bruce Willis didn't want to work and
part of this is going to be like
narrative convenience but they can't
they can't have conversations with David
because one David can just he's he's
otherwise a normal dude like he's not
he's he's doing vigilante work but it's
it's not like he's dressed up he's not
playing Watchmen you know he's not a
caped hero he's just you know puts on a
ski mask or whatever and puts on a rain
poncho and it's like oh the rain poncho
becomes like his his symbol even though
in unbreakable it was just it was
raining put on a poncho yeah and so it
becomes like it becomes like his
official costume it doesn't just become
a car
I mean at the start it's like it's still
kind of a thing of convenience like how
do you want to kind of look innocuous
it's like you put on a poncho its
Philadelphia it rains a lot but so he
doesn't have any sort of pretensions and
could very easily you know if they even
tried to have a conversation like the
natural written path of the conversation
would be David just being like what am I
doing here I'm just a dude who got I got
caught in I was like if the police want
to charge him with criminal activity for
his vigilantism sure sure but why is he
like you know like yeah I you know it's
like do you believe you're a superhero
no I know I I don't I don't yeah but
like he could just so easily deny it and
the other half of it is if he didn't
want to deny it the fact that he's like
super strong and ngayon vulnerable is
like empiric it's like demonstrable you
can just demonstrate that and so they
have so they avoid it they they get
around it by just never going there but
just ignoring him yeah but this is the
other thing okay so they get them to the
hospital so it you find out that
okay so there's they have a fight in the
brick factory and they fall out of a
window and then there's like all these
like cops lined up and a lady in a you
know white trench coat and they flash
all of these lights and it causes the
Beast to like go away because Kevin's
trick he's got two tricks
there's two tricks for dealing with
Kevin one is saying his real name well
that's easy which only one person ever
tries to actually do in this movie oh
wait no they do it one other person does
it but they that ones handled very and
the other one is flashing a bunch of
lights Adam in a pattern that forces
another personality to
take the light which is how they
described the like who's in control of
kevin time is this like who is standing
in the light and so they flash these
lights at him and that force is
basically a personality swap which so if
you're fighting the beast
well you swap to a non super-powered
personality and suddenly he's vulnerable
and it's like okay but so they take them
to not Arkham lock them up in in
specialized cells just just like in
Batman so Kevin's cell has a bunch of
lights next to the door so if he gets
too close to the door it like flashes
and forces of personality swap okay
which I guess I'm going to stop him from
Beast moding Kevin goes beast mode he's
a bad guy
yes because the Beast is a cannibal okay
but all most of his personalities are
also bad guys like one of them is has
declared herself High Priestess of the
Beast and wants to like purify the world
with her beast person and with her beast
she's gonna unleash the beast wait for
it
so flashes lights and that's so it's can
cancel beast mode with lights off but
then David's has all these like this
like sprinkler system set up inside of
it and I'm like
sar they gonna is that the plan like
just drown him just just keep human
environment but spritzing now and that's
the thing so like like with the
misbehaving dogs yes so he misbehaves
once and this is what this goes back to
so cheap is they don't show any of this
they don't turn it into an action
sequence of even the loosest kind like
he goes outside the building and you
hear this like pump start like you're
looking at this giant water reservoir
and this pump starts up and you hear
like sprinkler sounds in the soundtrack
and then it cuts to the interior of the
room
water like draining out through a grate
in the floor and David like sitting up
and like some water comes out of his
mouth but then like the room is
otherwise dry like the bed is dry he
sits on the bed and you hear it make
like a crinkle noises and and it's like
so they didn't fill the room to pacify
him they don't believe he's a superhero
why do they have the sprinklers because
all of a sudden water is just his
kryptonite but their whole thing is that
okay that the psychologist believes she
can cure him of his supernatural
abilities his demonstratively true
supernatural abilities through
psychology okay so second third twist of
the movie okay is that she actually like
this is very late in it and okay we'll
get okay we'll get to that what was the
thing what was the previous thing that I
said we needed to get to ok the Beast
you know what screw it let's just jump
to the end okay so a huge portion of
this movie an hour of this movie is
spent just like futzing around in the
hospital for no purpose it's a lot of
very cheaply shot conversations they
tried to make an aesthetic out of not
having reverse shots so like an entire
scene like there's a lot of points of
view there's entire scenes that are shot
just like looking at one character and
everybody like everybody else's dialogue
is off screen it's persistent enough
that it becomes aesthetic but one it's a
bad aesthetic and two it's obviously
getting around a very cramped shooting
schedule because they couldn't keep
paying for Sam and Bruce Bruce most of
the movies he does these days he has a
writer that he will only work one day
and everything else is done through
doubles so so I think for this they
probably got him for five okay he just
did not want to be there no and clearly
does not want to be there like does not
care he's happy he's he's not like bored
but he is completely checked out so a
huge chunk of the middle and we're just
gonna have to go past like all water
system and David's cell just vaguely our
were just screwing around in the
hospital how does the doctor oh the
doctor just knows a whole like
everything about David's past
oh there's Jackson told her everything
there's a scene no because he's being
kept in like a like heavily sedated
state why because he's now a super
villain with like Master Mind powers and
can like break out of anything and hack
any system and it's it's not that he had
done a bunch of research to figure out
how to cause a train to break it was
that he like knew of these systems
intimately I mean it's really funny
because in break in unbreakable
there's a scene where he like overhears
a bunch of people talking about the
hotel and you know basically saying sir
oh yeah man like that thing was built
back you know it's like I was staying in
there is it's wild it was built back in
like 1860 like it's totally not up to
code like there is not enough fire
escapes and and like you could see this
like oh okay if I just start a fire in
the hotel people will die because it's a
old hotel and isn't up to fire code and
doesn't have a proper sprinkler system
and there's no fire escapes he did not
like manufacture a convoluted sequence
of events that then caused a fire he
just went did some arson in an old
building and people died he was just an
opportunist yeah and but now he like now
he's like he he disassembles a laser and
like steals like this optical device out
of it in order to like trick the people
from thinking they were doing like this
like laser lobotomy on him okay
okay all right we were gonna talk about
weird beast we're gonna talk about the
beast but there's one other important
scene in the hospital which is when you
find out that he's been faking because
he's being like he's been switching all
of his pills with aspirin and using like
sleight of hand whatever but so he goes
and talks to Kevin and like I'd like to
meet the beast let's have you know blow
whatever he's leaving and Patricia who's
the High Priestess person out Kevin's
High Priestess personality is like and
what per say what her chance is your
name
and he's like wheeling out of the door
and he's like turns around first name
mister last name class and it's like
okay okay one this line would be bad
enough if he had just turned around and
said you can call me mr. glass or just
said mr. glass yes first name mister
last name glass wheels away okay couple
scenes like short scenes maybe three
minutes later flashback to him say first
name mister last name glass they liked
it so good they used twice alright let's
just jump to the end so there's a whole
set up about how it's like it's like the
tallest buildings in in Pennsylvania and
then it's like we're gonna go that like
there it's being it's having its grand
opening and so like the eyes of the
whole world are gonna be there and
you'll go and so his plan is that he's
gonna free the Beast and force David to
then fight the Beast in front of the
media so that the whole world will see
that superheroes are real he's waited
many many years to set this up surely he
could have created other confrontations
at an earlier point let's all right
let's put that aside let's just accept
that okay so they're gonna go fight like
I said this is a cheap movie and now
this is where it becomes the most
Shyamalan movie is that you can total
see minaj just sitting there thinking
like hey it's not us yeah it's gonna
save us money but also it's a subversion
and a twist they don't fight at the
towers they fight in the parking lot of
the hospital that we're already shooting
at okay so so it was a budget rate
that's supposed to be a twist so the
climax which goes on for a very long
time like about 25 minutes is in the
parking lot in front of the building
not in front of the big tall tower in
front of the hospital I'd ask why they
decide to fight there but I guess it
really doesn't matter it's and and it's
so is he sad that they don't go all the
way to the towers he picked out to fight
like that they decide to fight there to
screw with him like fine we'll do your
show fight but we'll just do it here cuz
we are feeders or we don't feel like
walking so they've got this huge lead on
David and they get up to the parking lot
and then they just like they just dick
around like tipping over security cars
like the the Beast
like tips over a car and then grabs a
couple nurses and throws them into the
back of a van and then David comes out
he's like you stop right there and then
they have their showdown okay so the
supernatural elements have been
heightened from unbreakable okay but
they haven't been heightened that much
everybody's pretending or everybody's
talking as though the Beast and David
are you know like Superman and doomsday
going a town on each other as we have
seen in so many
so many superhero blockbusters yeah so
the final the final final final twist is
that the footage of this fight gets out
and yeah oh wait no I need to back up
one twist so the doctor she actually
like works for this nebulous
organization that I'll have clover
tattoos on their wrists so the clover
organization the clover organization has
been protecting the world for 10,000
years from super-powered people and so
they just like they fight super-powered
people and then they basically just like
kill them they've manufactured their
deaths and okay
but so she's also trying to prevent all
of this from getting out and then the
like final twist is that all the footage
gets out because there's all these
security cameras and mr. glass hacked
the security cameras and streamed it to
an exterior server and it all gets out
but so this is where it just all
culminates in being hilarious
because the fight between the beast and
David it's all security camera angles so
it's wide angles high up looking down so
this is just too jacked up dudes like
wrestling in a parking lot it's like
it's like you know he the Beast pics
like lifts up a car and tips it over and
it's like okay cool I saw somebody do
that on Spike TV last week I can find
800 YouTube videos of dudes who are like
today I'm gonna tip a car huh I'm gonna
pull a tractor-trailer I'm gonna we've
loaded up my Ford f-150 with 30 with 30
steel plates and I'm gonna pull it by my
belt and it's like it's like okay strong
yeah why would anyone believe this this
footage is authentic and this is the
thing is so the movie already kind of
like references this discontinuity in
that like in the
at convincing David this is like
convincing him that he's not actually
super-powered there's the flashback to
unbreakable where Bruce Willis actually
has acting skills again and he he's
talking to Jacob what Joseph he's
talking to Joseph and says you know
Joseph's like you're a superhero dad and
and David says it's like son there's
guys in every gym across this country
who can lift that much like what I did
is like it's impressive but it's not
special like you know let's keep this
some perspective so like they call
attention to that and so when if you've
already got that line like rattling in
the back of your brain and you're
watching the Beast to do crazy
unbelievable proof of superhuman
strength by just like rolling a car over
he doesn't even do it like he doesn't
even like pick up the nose and like flip
it he like goes from the side like from
like the driver's side door and it's
like okay so you tipped it the easy way
like you you tipped it the way that if I
were to be like okay I bet if me and
four friends got together we could
probably tip a sedan over the where we
would stand we it's like no of course
we're not gonna do it from the nose
where ken is going from the side we're
gonna do it the short way cuz that's
where it's gonna pivot better and so
it's like and leading up to him tipping
it like actually like he just like
Ramsey with his shoulder a few times and
so you've just got these shots of like
superhuman strength it's just shirtless
james mcavoy like body checking a car
and then like same thing with David like
he punches this like panel van it's like
it leaves dents and it's like okay you
dented a van by punching it like okay it
looks more like a bar fight this entire
you unconvincing but it leaks so so
Joseph the girl from the girl from split
and and Elijah's mom leaked this to the
Internet and they're all sitting there
in Penn Station like when did the upload
finish actual line
when did the upload wet or when was it
posted when was it posted two hours ago
and I'm just sitting there like if
they're posting this to YouTube like I
really want this just to end with like
them like sitting there looking at their
stats pages and it's like seven hits no
it's like it but it goes instantly viral
with people like watching these videos
of like James McAvoy typical Ike the
news is now like talking about it and
it's like it's like none of this is
remotely except she likes in like the
the Chiron is like escaped mental
patients your psych mental patients
escaped from like blah blah blah
hospital and then it's like the footage
of him tipping the car and and it's like
okay I can see why that would maybe be
on the news because like yeah mental
patient gets that and tip and rolls over
a rolls over a security car like yeah
that'll do some rounds on the news as
they like you won't believe what's
happening in Philly but it's like yeah
it's like this peeks at like Florida man
and yet and yet the framing of it is
that it's like this is going to restore
humanity's faith in the in the
unbelievable in the spectacular in the
supernatural that like we've become so
jaded we're so Jay
now bye-bye
being sold products that we no longer
believe in in real superheroes
why why
so on the cinematography side on the
composition side student film they've
managed to get a couple big-name actors
you know like clearly like a lack of
coverage that they've tried to work
around as aesthetic an excessive use of
like gimmicky camera angles limited to
like two locations you know it reminds
me of all the student films that I did
like you watch stuff from Satan's like
you can always tell when they shot in
the classroom because it's like you see
the scenes very clearly shot so I didn't
see these are clearly shot it's like I
know you say yeah Center yeah oh man
okay the first fight scene the Beast
this is terrifying unstoppable being
like picks up a table and throws it and
then David catches it just like throws
it back and so this is like this is like
so let's roll back Patricia's whole plan
to like purify the world with the with
this like people will see the beast and
they will cower in fear and it's like so
he is super tough like he can take he
can take a shot gun shot how does he
hold up to like a cop with a gun yes so
he can he can take a blast from a
shotgun but he is otherwise like he can
climb like he can climb vertical walls
and climb on the ceiling he can tap a
cop car not not exactly the kind of
thing that's gonna gonna be like you
know kidnapped the Queen of England and
hold her hostage and that is the
exchange rate so that the Bank of
England will sets
or bison dollars once I kidnapped that
Queen you know it's not exactly global
domination stuff it's more roll a
7-eleven and get away with a couple
hundred bucks for the police eventually
chase you down and SWAT takes you out
like it's and these unlike you know it's
it's not like it's not like they they're
leaking this footage of people
concerning you know fire or whatever but
even if they did that it's like okay
we're gonna leak it on YouTube we're
gonna put it on YouTube and it's like
peels on you people at one anything if
if they did see it it just be like Oh
rad another special effects channel cool
I love roosterteeth do you guys are you
guys gonna do anything with rocketjump
do you know them you should do so you
should do a crossover with rocket jump
or even better hey I have that red giant
plug in like it is clear is clear that M
night Shyamalan has never actually
posted a YouTube video you know what I'm
just gonna lightly glance across the
scene where a underage girl is
encouraged to that that she can tame the
Beast with pure physical affection will
just lightly glance across that it's a
scene that happens there's a huge
interrogation scene where she's got all
three in the same room it's really
stupid most of this movie like it's a
lot like split in the huge chunks of the
movie are basically just James McAvoy
Hamming for the camera and it's super
impressive because he like switches
characters and it's like yes he's an
actor and in fact this kind of character
switching like rapid character switching
it's called a one-person play and it's
really really really really really
really really really really common as an
acting exercise
his actual power he's just an actor his
actual power yeah his actual power it's
like okay James McAvoy has taken a
couple theater classes rad he's pretty
good at it but it's like this is not you
know this is not Laurence Olivier stuff
here I'm sorry yeah so I guess the one
thing I left out of the climax the one
thing I mentioned the clover thing but
so he's her name Claire
the girl from split like stalks the
beast down and brings Kevin out and then
he gets shot by a sniper and then that's
the first you see of the clover tattoo
is it's like Oh a camera like swings
across and it's like snuck through there
it's like you see the clover tattoo on
his thumb and then they like drag David
over to this water puddle and like drown
him and then and then mr. glass is like
I was I was well you say he was wrong or
he was lying that it's like this wasn't
this wasn't this wasn't the climax of a
special edition this was an origin story
all along
I am only barely paraphrasing this that
sounds like the type of line you put in
at the end to make it seem like it was
all like super smart and if you're
confused it's because you're not clever
enough to get what's actually going on
cuz we only had 15 shooting days only
five of the Bruce was only gonna be
around for five of those there's there's
a scene where Bruce Willis does crime
and it's not even him it's a stand-in he
wasn't even like their crime scene
there's a lot of there's actually
there's less of that than you get in an
actual like modern Bruce Willis film but
there's still a decent amount of it this
movie was awful why why make it at all I
think that's about all I have to say
about I don't know that's that's all I
can think of right now I'm sure there's
more that will come
to me but that that was that was glass
hey Amy come here I need a closing shot
it's Amy don't go see glass